All right. Nothing like coming back from
vacation to a GPU launch. Anyway, uh
okay. So, it's 5060 Ti time to talk
about the 5060Ti, which probably is
going to cost
$86,000 by the time this video goes live
with if the last week is any indicator
of just how [__] up everything is
today. Is that the logo? Yes. Today's
video is brought to you by the new
really super cool JUSense melty
connector shirt. You know, paying
tribute to one of the best designs
that's clearly ever existed. And if you
don't like the vapor wave colors, we got
our OG gray and red colors available
now. So get yours by following the link
in the description below. Nice. Ow, I
have a thigh cramp. And since that
intro, it's now
$57,000. Anyway, moving moving on.
Moving on, which I I'm just I'm going
with it. Okay, 56 50 560 Ti 16 GB
variant cuz as I've already talked about
a bunch of times in a few different
videos, it's an 8 GB and a 16 GB uh
version of this card just like there was
with the 4060 uh or 460 Ti. But one
thing you need to point out as we move
forward with these charts and stuff is
our 560 Ti is a 16 GB variant. I have no
idea if anyone received an 8 GB model,
but because I bitched and whined so hard
about it, I'm sure they made sure to
send me a 16 GB card for that very
reason. We also were supposed to have an
ASUS card to kind of compare um cuz
there there is no reference design or no
there is a reference. There's no there's
no Founders Edition card for the 560Ti
which is kind of strange cuz we had one
for the 4060 Ti and it came in this big
ass box for no reason whatsoever. I mean
look at the size of the card versus the
inside of this box. Anyway, it's on the
test bench over there actually running
of the best troll of all time. So I have
no idea if anyone received an 8 GB. So,
I need to preface this with saying
comparing to our 4060 Ti benchmarks and
our 3060 Ti, they are 8 GB cards,
whereas this is a 16 GB. Um, anyway, so
of course we're going to talk about the
normal [__] performance, power draw,
temperature, generational performance,
uplift, and all that good stuff. So, key
specifications, 560 Ti is a GB 206 core
with 4,68 CUDA cores running at 2572 MHz
uh boost clock. 4060 Ti is on 8106 4352
CUDA cores at uh 2535. That's important
to note specifically because we know
that the process for 50 series and 40
series is essentially the same. So the
any clock speed and CUDA core change is
actually going to be beneficial like
almost directly relatable generation to
generation where typically you have a
whole different family of core to
compare like the 3060 Ti running on amp
or G104 even though it has the most CUDA
corores of the three at
4,864 it only runs at 1665 MHz. Remember
that was a Samsung node that Samsung
designed or or fabbed that where they're
back on TSMC for 40 series and 50
series. Now, another thing to point out
is because this is a partner card, this
is the PNY OC overclocked, which that's
the same thing. OC is Oh, Anyway, I
digress. Apparently, I go on vacation
for a week and the world really does go
crazy while I'm gone. Oh, and also the
3060 Ti is also a Gigabyte uh gaming OC
card, whereas the 460Ti that we've
compared it is an FE card. Now, the FE
card is technically, for all intents and
purposes, also a partner card. It's just
Nvidia's making their own partner card.
So, it is got a slightly higher clock
speeds and such than what the basic
reference design would be. So, it's
still a completely fair comparison with
the exception of the fact that two of
the cards are completely neutered to
half the RAM of what they should have.
Uh, the RT cores uh in the 5060 Ti,
there's 36 of the fourth gen RT cores.
460Ti has 34 of the third gen. 3060Ti
has 38 of the second gen. So once you're
going to notice here on paper the 3060
Ti and the reason why I'm talking about
these three cards is the most relevant
to anyone considering upgrading in that
price point.
Um whatever the hell the price is going
to end up being. But I digress. Uh it's
got higher specs on paper with on
everything with the exception of the
clock speeds. So that's important to
note cuz it is running at more than a 1
ghahz disadvantage on the effective
clock speed versus what the boost clocks
are. So, as you know, GPU Boost can push
the cards higher than their actual
advertised boost clock speeds based on
power draw, temperatures, and overhead
of of any of the the three, including
the max bin boost clock that's available
to it in the uh the V BIOS. Anyway,
tensor cores 560 Ti has 144 of them on
the fifth gen tensor core. 4060 has 136
of them on the fourth gen tensor core.
And the 3060 Ti once again has the most
at 152, but they're third gen. So, we
are several gen ahead. You might be
wondering why the gen is off one versus
the RT cores. Remember back when like
the Titan Volulta existed. It was the
first card that had tensor cores. It had
no RT cores. It had tensor cores. So by
the time 20 series rolled around, they
were already on second gen tensor but
first gen RT. So that's why if you're
wondering why there's a numerical
generation offset there. That is why
memory. This is where the cards
definitely uh kind of differ from each
other. So 560Ti is running GDDDR7 which
is what all of 50 series is running. has
16 GB of it. There is 8 GB available at
$50 less than this card, which MSRP is
for
$429 prior to whatever pissing match is
taking place in the world. You should
not buy an 8 GB card even though it's 50
bucks cheaper at
$379. It should not exist, period. We've
already showed that as why that exists
and or should not exist and our charts
will even kind of demonstrate that as we
move forward today. uh but it's on a 128
bit bus running at 448 gigabytes per
second effective uh bandwidth. Now the
4060 Ti has 8 gigabytes of GDDDR6
uh 16 GB is available. That should be
the only one you ever considered, but I
priced it to like the other day and it
was $1,000 for that card. Uh so no, it
would never be on on any planet worth
that price. again the same 120 bit bus
but 288 gigabyte per second effective uh
transfer rate. So that is when you look
at the charts and you see the 4060 Ti
and just how terrible it is. Um it's
probably because of that to be honest.
Now the 3060 Ti has 8 GB of
GDDDR6 quotes. There is a G6X version
which we also did not know really
existed. Um, it's not really easy to
find that card, but you can get it with
a faster RAM, but they're on a 256-bit
bus at the same 458 GB per second uh
transfer speed as the 560Ti. So, the
3060Ti was kind of ahead of its time in
terms of the RAM per the the tier it
belongs and or the other cards just got
behind where they should be to be
honest. But the fact that we're selling
a 128 bit bus getting the same 448 GB
per second that the 256-bit bus is
getting on the 3060Ti is a testament to
how good and fast G7 really is. Power
requirements 5060 Ti is 180 watt card
recommending a 450 watt power supply.
460Ti is 160 watt card recommending the
same 450 watt. 3060 Ti is the slowest
card in this chart with the highest
power draw. 200 watts with a recommended
550 watts of uh recommended power
supply. Now, we're not going to go
through all the charts. The charts are
actually getting kind of cluttered now,
to be honest, cuz there's so many cards
on there. I might just start figuring
out how I'm going to curate showing you
this data. We're just going to run
through them, play some heavy metal
music or some [__] for you guys to
listen to, and bang your heads on the
table like the rest of us. And we're
going to highlight the 560 Ti, and you
can just kind of notice where it lands
on the various uh tests and
[Music]
resolutions. Yeah,
Okay, so just a couple of mentions here.
one, the 56 uh 560 Ti had a lot of
quirks in this test. Um, as you guys
know, Nvidia is struggling with drivers
right now. For whatever reason, the
Nvidia driver team is just dropping the
ball at every chance that it's getting.
Now, you might notice that our 1% lows
or 99th percentile on the 5070 came back
up to normal because we retested that
card as we s as we uh sort of like
predicted. the
weird frame pacing that we were seeing
with like a weird spike in every single
test was uh existing on a press driver
for us and with the latest drivers that
all smoothed out. It gained a little bit
in some tests and gained or lost a
little in some tests and that kind of
happens sometimes with different driver
variations and such. So although the
5070s 1% lows have normalized, the 5060
started having some weirdness in various
tests like F1. it was kind of giving
some weird inconsistent times where
sometimes uh Phil actually did uh the
testing for the 560 Ti on this one, but
he had to rerun the test quite a bit
because of huge stutters and delays that
would actually be so bad it would throw
off the entire test result and you'd
have to throw it away and start all over
again. So that's why it's to mention
here press drivers do this most of the
time and then the official release
driver that comes out like tomorrow from
the time you guys are watching this
almost always fixes that. But why they
can't get that fixed prior to press
release uh is beyond me. Let's go ahead
and talk and but I want to point out if
you go back and look at the charts, the
relevant performance of the card nearest
to the 5060 Ti is not consistent. It
depends on the test. So Blackm Wukong,
for instance, loves 50 series. For
whatever reason, it absolutely loves the
50 series architecture, which is weird
cuz it's technically the same
architecture. So the 560 Ti is actually
right there with the 3090. Only in that
one test, though. It's not like suddenly
the 3090 is now 56 uh 5060 Ti
performance level. That's almost as
crazy as saying the 5070 is as fast as a
4090, which we all know how that turned
out. That ended up being one of the
biggest marketing lies with asterisks
all the way across the screen. Um, but
then you know, you look at certain other
titles like Borderlands or F1 or
whatever and then it goes down in the
lower third of the chart where it
belongs cuz it is more of an entry-level
card and as of right now it is the
lowest end card Nvidia offers in the
modern product stack at least until the
5060 comes out next month in May. Okay,
so power draw test. This is done on
Steel Nomad. We tried Steel Nomad this
time around cuz it's actually a very
good uh realistic rasterization test.
It's the it's the most demanding 3D Mark
test that's ever existed. Uh, that's a
nonRT test. And, you know, to be honest,
the RT performance of these lower-end
cards are okay. But, uh, I don't think
that should be the selling point the
farther down the stack you go because
you take a really big hit in
performance. And don't forget, even if
you're using multi-gen uh, or frame gen,
multi-frame gen, which we did not even
bother testing with this card, the input
frame rate is what all of that is based
on. So DLSS and multif frame gen and all
that if you have a very low input frame
specifically multi-gen the perceived lag
or response time click to photon thing
on the screen is very very laggy. So
although on the higherend cards it's a
lot less noticeable because the base
frame rate is so much higher uh not
recommended on the lowerend cards as far
as I'm concerned. That's my personal
opinion. Nvidia would say I'm full of
[__] Take it as for what it is. So
anyway, on the power draw test though in
Steel Nomad, we ran it for 15 minutes.
It's a 4K test. Uh this is both PCI
Express slot power combined with PCI
Express power or 12vt high power
depending on the the card. This is a 8
pin PCI Express cable. It's the first
one in the 50 series to actually only
have an 8 pin PCI Express. Kind of
doesn't make sense to have a 12volt high
power on this. It also doesn't make
sense to have the power plug all the way
up near the freaking IO bracket. What
this is all about, I have no idea. PNY.
someone your design team over there
needs to be fired, they're on crack. Uh
anyway, so if we take a look at the
power charts right here, they land
pretty much exactly where the TDP says
that they should. Uh and this is
measured hardware-wise, not just what
the software is reporting. Software
always reports a lower number than
hardware cuz hardware takes for account
heat losses and other inefficiencies in
the actual burning of energy to create a
thing on a screen. So hovering right
around 180 to 185. sometimes spiking
over 190 or right at 190 is a 5060 Ti.
Again, 180 watt card. The 4060 Ti 8 GB
card is a 160 watt card. And as you can
see, it just dances and line dances all
over that 160 watt line. The 3060 Ti is
a 200 W card, but as you can see, it is
actually pulling over 220 watts fairly
consistently. So, that's 10% more power
than it's actually advertised to draw.
So that's why earlier in this review I
said the 3060 Ti was actually the
highest mo most inefficient card on the
table and the slowest which shows how
far uh the TSMC process is versus
Samsung. So anyway, moving on to core
temperatures though cuz power and
temperature are directly related. Again,
the same steel Nomad test looping for 15
minutes. Uh look at the 3060 Ti 8 GB
line though. It's actually very very
tight toy like toer right across the 65
watt or excuse me the 65 Celsius line.
Not bad at all. Again factory fan curves
no change. But what I think is
interesting is both the 5060 Ti and the
4060 Ti which are both like dual fan and
triple fan cards respectively. This is
the 3060 Ti that was tested right here,
the Gigabyte OC card. So you can see
it's a triple fan versus a double fan.
Uh both of those have some fairly wild
swings of about five degrees up and down
throughout the test. So Steel Nomad is
designed and the different parts of the
test actually do different things when
it comes to uh rendering the frame. So
that's why they kind of fluctuate
depending on some increased and
decreased workload, which also tests for
stability. So it allows the core clocks
to kind of climb and drop and climb and
drop and power and move around with it.
So it's kind of intended to also hunt
out instabilities. So that's why the
yellow line looks so good because the
3060Ti was hit so hard it kind of pegged
the power limit which pegged the
temperature and really couldn't do
anything beyond that. The other cards
look like uh scribbles which is kind of
interesting. Now I also did do a VRAMm
temperature test on the 560 Ti. 4060s TI
and 3060Ti are absent from this chart
because for whatever reason hardware
info 64, which is what I was using to
actually monitor the junk memory
junction temperature, the sensor doesn't
show up for those two cards there, but
it does for the 5060 Ti, which is ironic
because there's no hotspot temp on 50
series, but the other cards do have
hotspot temp, but they're such low power
cards anyway. I mean that that's why
they're hovering around that uh you know
65 watt or 65 C whereas the 5060 is you
know hitting about 72C and then the 4060
is sitting there right around 65 C. So
that's why there's such a big
temperature swing with them. But as you
can see the memory capped out at about
72° C. A little warmer than actually
expected for this little guy. then again
is GDDDR7 and there is 16 GB of it on
there and it is such a tiny PCB and so
much of the cooler is actually
overhanging over here and not directly
like a huge chunk of it above the
memory. Uh I'm not surprised it actually
got a little warmer than I would have
expected. Another thing to point out too
is it's actually the quietest card on
the bench. In fact, whether the fans are
turning or not, you pretty much can't
hear it. It's pretty damn quiet to be
honest. When I was doing my temperature
draw test uh on it, I didn't hear any
ramp. I mean, it does it did. It's just
it's so quiet and turning so slow that
uh it's completely inaudible, which is
one of the reasons why the memory
temperatures are a little bit on the
elevated side. Nothing concerning, but
definitely elevated. I would expected
them to be more in the 50s or 60s rather
than the mid70s given the fact that it's
not a very high-end card. Um, but it was
a hard test to run. So, that can
actually uh stress the memory quite a
bit. I did check memory util and actual
the memory controller uh status and such
on this card and it was full tilt for
the memory. It's not like the memory was
sitting there doing nothing because it
wasn't like a an actual playable game.
It was just a synthetic test, but it did
load up the RAM. Let's go and talk about
core frequencies here. So, remember when
I talked about the 3060 Ti being that
slowest card on the chart, but also the
highest power power consumption. I mean,
remember it was uh what was the actual
uh clock? Yeah, 1665 MHz. So, it
actually boosted to almost 1,900 MHz.
So, we got an additional 300 above,
well, 250 above where it's supposed to
go. But if you compare it to its, you
know, its younger brothers, it it can't
compete. I mean, the 460Ti is hovering
right around that 2700 MHz, and the 5060
Ti is just under 2900, staying above
2,800 the entire test. So that's what I
said earlier about the fact that
although there are 512 less CUDA cores
in the 5060Ti, it has a significant uh
clock speed increase which definitely
has made up for it. It would have been
awesome if they had the same CUDA core
count with that higher clock speed, but
that would have probably encroached on
the 5070 or the 50Ti super that they're
probably designing and making. But clock
speeds are only half of the story. What
happens if we start talking about frame
times? So, for instance, we look at
Cyberpunk 2077 here in 1440p. I normally
would cut the chart to where all the
frames are uh like and making it to the
end of the chart, but I thought this was
a neat representation of the fact that
you can see that the 560 Ti is drawing
more frames in the same amount of time
than the other two cards. So, you can
see as the cards get slower, there's
less of those frames being drawn in this
chart because less frames were actually
rendered in the same amount of time.
That's what lower FPS or frames per
second means. Uh, but look at how actual
tight and consistent the 5060 Ti is,
specifically in Cyberpunk. Not bad at
all. What's interesting about the 4060
Ti is not only do we have the most
spikes in high frame times, we also have
the most spikes in low frame times.
Spikes in low are the same as spikes in
high when you compare it to the frames
next to it. So if you have high and low
spikes, you're only putting a bigger gap
between what it took to draw the frames
on either side of it. So those are
perceived as stutters or hiccups or
jitter. And inconsistent frame times are
way worse than higher average frame
times. I personally would always take a
more consistent slightly higher frame
time than a more fluctuating with more
spikes and dips in frame times. uh
because those, like I said, are
perceived as inconsistencies. And you
can see the 3060 Ti also had a few of
those big spikes and on average was
higher than that or higher than the
other cards. And that's just FPS turned
into a how long did it take to draw the
frame and that's what it looks like. But
a title that actually runs pretty
consistent as Avatar Frontiers of
Pandora. Uh again, 1440p high preset, no
frame gen, no upscaling. Uh you can see
right now that all three cards actually
perform very similar with the amount of
like spikes that there are except for
the 3060 Ti right in the middle of the
test as you can see had a couple real
close together really high spikes up to
nearly 40 milliseconds. That would be
perceived as a good hiccup in the game.
Uh but as you can see 5060 Ti keeps it
pretty tight down fairly low. So you can
see at the start of the test it starts
starts at about 16 milliseconds and then
progressively comes down to about 15 and
kind of hovers there. And then the other
two cards actually follow that same
curve. They're just about 18
milliseconds and about 22 milliseconds
respectively. So they just look like the
same crayon. Like you took three crayons
and just drew across a page. That's what
it looks like. Let's talk about relative
performance now because this is this is
going to be interesting to anyone
potentially running a 3060 Ti or 4060 Ti
and consider upgrades. You know, I'm
going to be honest right now. I'm be
honest and and and this is why I
revamped my testing suite actually goes
back to almost two years ago when I had
a surgery and so I couldn't do the 4060
Ti review and Phil did it for me.
Following the guidance I gave him which
was very poor in how to test this sort
of stuff led us to draw some conclusions
that actually were not indicative of the
real story. This chart right here,
specifically regarding relative
performance compared to 3060 Ti, made me
understand today in full clarity, the
aha about why there was so much push
back that actually led to me pulling
down the only review I've ever pulled
down since starting this channel. And
that's no fault of Phil's because that's
the guidance I gave him. So that's why I
I totally get the outrage of when uh we
were like, "The 4060 Ti is not that
bad." Well, no. A generational uplift
and a memory [__] uh leading to a 10%
performance uplift at the carrot dangled
of we at least we didn't raise the price
is why the outrage was there and I get
it now 100% but it really took revamping
the entire testing suite uh to sort of
get that fleshed out and I'm happy I did
that now. So for instance 5060 Ti in F1
is 19.6% faster than a 460 Ti and 31.5%
as I already said faster than a uh than
a 3060 Ti. So definitely very
noticeable. Now Blackmth Wukong the 3060
Ti at 100% the 460 Ti in that particular
test like every generation especially
because it's a full rate trace test sees
a huge improvement in the new cards
because of the rate tracing improvements
in the newer RT cores. So for instance
460Ti is 33.8% 8% faster or higher score
in average FPS than the uh Blackmint
Wukong or than the 3060 Ti and
63% higher uh with the 5060 Ti, which
also means that the 5060 Ti was 21.9%
faster than a 4060 Ti in the same, you
know, generation increase. So, one gen
newer. So, Borderlands 3 only 9.1%
improvement for 4060 Ti over 3060 Ti,
but 32.3% improvement for 5060 Ti over
3060 Ti and 21.3% improvement over 4060.
So, we're seeing bigger generational
improvements in the in the factor of
like double or more with 5060 versus
4060. And again, that's probably going
to come down to the RAM to be quite
honest. Let's see. Avatar Frontiers of
Pandora 14% faster for 4060 Ti than 3060
Ti and 30 effectively 30% or 29.9%
faster for 5060 over 3060 Ti. 5060 Ti
was 14% faster than 4060. So, two more
tests to talk about here. Cyberpunk 2077
version 2.12 only 5% faster or 5.1% for
4060 Ti 8 gig over 30. And think about
think about that clock speed I showed
you. the fact that it is more than a
gigahertz faster and it's only giving
you 5% improvement. That's that's not
good. So, yeah, that now I'm happy I
took down that review because I'm I've
got full eye openen like enlightenment
right now as to why the push back and
the outrage of that video. And then the
560 Ti is 42% faster than a 3060 Ti uh
in Cyberpunk. So nearly nearly, you
know, a whole half a card faster, if you
will, and it's 35% faster than a 50 than
a 4060 Ti. Now, let's talk about the
total relative performance. And as you
saw that in a chart, you can see the
purple line representing the uh 5060 Ti
is obviously significantly higher in
most cases away from the 4060 than the
4060 was uh versus the 3060. So,
relative performance here, 5060 Ti was
on average across our test, and you'll
notice there's a title missing. I'll
explain why in a second. 21.3% faster
than 4060 Ti. That is actually, believe
it or not, the biggest jump or just
about the biggest jump we've seen yet
when comparing a 50 series to a 40
series card. Remember, all the other
stuff was anywhere between like 11% 14%.
And if we outly and take this stuff
away, maybe 19%, but
21.3%. Still not great in my opinion.
We're used to seeing 23 25 28% sometimes
30% faster with generational uplift.
Don't forget it's essentially the same
process. So, it's going to be hard for
them to get that. And the way that
they're getting it on this guy is the
same as the way they did it on 5090 and
everything else. Actually, in this
instance, not really more CUDA cores,
but more power limit and more frequency.
So, they really heavily leaned into the
bin and the improvement of the process
than actually being a new process. And
56Ti is on average 37.6 6 faster than
the 3060 Ti. The reason why 20% feels
pretty good in this is because of the
fact that I I actually didn't do the
figure of what the generational uplift
was on 4060 Ti versus 3060 Ti, but it
was complete [__] Like if we take
Blackmth out of there, which a 33.8%
improvement for 4060 Ti, it would be
barely 10% if that. And don't forget,
you got downgraded in the memory along
the way. It was like half the effective
speed essentially. 128 bit bus versus
256. And yes, the 5060 Ti is on a two or
128 bit bus. It has double the RAM
though, and it's faster RAM, so it's
kind of like getting towed by that, if
you will. But certain titles start to
show problems with certain cards with
when it comes to VRAM allocation and
availability. You'll notice that uh
Horizon Forbidden West is not even on
here. That's because of the fact that we
actually noticed some weird nuances here
where 3060 Ti in our charts was actually
beating 4060 Ti, which was really,
really odd. See, these are these are
cards that we've tested and since our
last review, they weren't on the charts
and they would have been today.
Although, we had to like completely nyx
that title entirely and kind of start
over because we noticed severe swings
from run to run on the average 99th
percentile and 95th percentile uh FPS
numbers to the point to where every
single time we ran the test, the
performance got lower for the card. Even
if you restarted the title and ran it
again, you would get completely
different numbers than the first time
you ran the title. So, it became to the
point to where I would actually love to
challenge Steve to find out why the [__]
why that is because now we've got I
don't know 30 cards we have to retest on
a different title because it looked like
it was going to be a good one and it's
not. So, we don't understand what it's
doing. Uh to to to basically say it
doesn't matter if it's a 5090 or a 7600
XT, you get fluctuating performance
every single time. Initially, we thought
it might have been because we had
dynamic resolution going, which is
actually a very bad thing to have going
on a benchmark because if you don't hit
the target FPS of 60, which is what the
title's trying to maintain, it will in
real time start lowering the the base
resolution and then kind of upscaling it
back to what your monitor or your game
is set to to try and maintain that 60
fps. So, it can be fluctuating and
moving, giving you very inconsistent
numbers. Now, we disabled the dynamic
resolution to see what would happen.
Like, will we get some consistent
numbers, and it didn't fix the problem.
Didn't matter if it's 5090, which we
know is well above 60 fps, or all the
way down to the the 4060 Ti, which was
giving us the worst numbers. Actually,
we were actually seeing numbers of well
over fps in the lower-end cards, restart
the title, and then get down into the
20s. So, we're talking obviously a 50%
performance swing. Had to actually throw
that title out. So, we're going to have
to find a new title to put in there
because I I need a bigger size of
sampling when it comes to these cards to
give relevant information. But,
fortunately, I think we have enough
information here to make it relevant to
you. One other thing I want to talk
about here, at least on this particular
card on its physical size, it is tiny
AF. Not only do I hate the location of
the plug, this is the worst. There's
there is no way to cable manage the plug
there. PNY. Do you know what's right
above the graphics card? The
motherboard. Do you know what's directly
above the motherboard? Usually an AIO or
fans or something. So, if they thought
you were going to run this up along
through the EPS power and then back down
to your power supply, you'd never have a
c cable long enough to reach that. In
fact, our cable on our test bench can
barely reach this because we run it
through the PMD2. So, it is by far one
of the stupidest designs I've ever seen.
And yeah, I said stupid cuz they had to
say the emphasis of the word stupid to
get you to realize how dumb this really
is. And not only that, if you look at
the board, there's plenty of room where
they could have absolutely put the plug
there. Half the board is [__] empty.
There's nothing on it. The card could
literally stop right where the T is on
RTX if you wanted cuz it's bare from
that side over. PNY. Yeah. PN Why do you
hate
us? Anyway, it's that I don't like that
design. Uh the card weighs like nothing.
There's no lights on it whatsoever. The
only thing it really has going for it is
the fact that it is damn near silent.
But at
$429 before any sort of markups and
pissing matches taking place in the
world, it's a it's it should be $379 and
16 GB. That's really what it should be.
It should not be a $50 premium for
having what the card should have always
had to begin with. But you know what?
leave it to Nvidia to find a way to
basically well, let's see, [__] you at
the start when it comes to the base
price, which is only going to then
percentually percentage- wise screw you
even more on the tail end because that
percentage increase is based on the base
price, which should be $50 lower to
begin with.
I I don't really have anything else to
say about it other than it's there.